you've been doing some very important
work on the financial aspects of FTTH
provision what can you tell us about it
well on behalf of the ftth council i
have been involved with the COS project
and that's an attempt to calculate
bottom up the total investment needed to
fiber eyes the whole of Europe based on
the digital digital agenda Digital
Agenda Europe broadband targets to to
estimate the total cost needed to give
fiber to all Europeans of the old 27
European countries based on the targets
set by the European Commission sounds
like quite a project what are some of
the main conclusions were they
surprising can you tell us a little bit
about it yeah we were surprised about
the results because the current figure
is circulating is about 260 to 280
billion euros and our results show that
the total if as Benitez is lower
significantly lower we have we have
found a figure which is lower and we
looking forward to to publish that
tomorrow and to present the results in
more detail well that sounds great news
that everybody will be welcoming and in
the meantime thanks for sharing it with
us Thank You O'Brien FTTH connects the
world
when are you getting connected ladies
and gentlemen welcome to Munich for the
ninth edition of the ftth conference
creating a brighter future